Будь ти пішов війною до України обосрался
і не пройшло тепер у Європі та у всьому
світі кожен знає Путін [ __ ] Будь ти
пішов війною в Україну обосрався і не
пройшов тепер у Європі та у всьому світі
буде [ __ ] поїхали Двері закривай
[музика]
[оплески]
Доброго дня Путін
ви знаходитесь в країні, у якого
20 відсотків ми не раді вас бачити ми не
будемо вас зустрічати з посмішкою на обличчі
[музика]
Я купив і прийшов
Ванька Гліб та Матвій
викрадав і курей і дусі мишинки Шанель
за брата
шемаг-бук Так я прийшов
один пук-бук
[музика]
тобі сказати
на сході Україна Донбас
пішаки прийшли в Західній іконі сиськи Як
ти думаєш на цьому Зара кричать пам'ятайте
ми найбільша армія світу пам'ятаєте ми
найбільша армія світу і ми прийшли тільки
за перемогу Ми прийшли ще й за горілкою
[оплески]
сьогодні більшість із вас загине Але
пам'ятайте Це не просто так це за Путіна
за Путіна
поїзди там усім
[музика]
батальйону Архангела Михайла
я скажу яка різниця взагалі які
букети їх орати
російські йдуть
музей Поле чудес
[музика]
це виходить у нас як виходить
Виходить потреба цікаво американці
написали латинськими літерами на
українською мовою
а перед стрілянням
затикай вуха
[музика]
стріляємо кілька
правого ременя
Мене звуть Ваня я з Рязані вмію
стріляти і торгую салямі але так як
салямі сім'ю не прогодуєш пішов
постріляти але куди блясти не пам'ятаю
я точно що за кордон інші деталі
не важлива в принципі назва цих усіх
країні для мене є Росія і не Росія
армія наші аналогів
чим більше запущено різних ракет тим
простіше закрити без розриву бюджет армія
наша мильна бульбашка надута
[музика]
[оплески]
переговорний процес Ми на відміну від
деяких наших партнерів
все ти намагаюся культуру дипломатичних
Переговори витримувати хоча
доброго вечора
російський військовий корабель
Йди на [ __ ]
Дай я гадаю ти з України ти нові ритуал
Прочитати все нові сокира твоя
обітканий кінь твій акінату а
дубаний підвал а бомбет рівний фарбу
чутки ласку Ти знаєш
[музика]
українською
пігулким жиром
і це допоможе заговорити українською не
то допоможе
[музика]
і помчала
шкірний тут свій річки тут і ковдри
аптечки та каремати
[музика]